just wanted to make a quick video to let
everyone know that the newshour with jim
lehrer i think it's called the PBS
Newshour now let me write that down PBS
the PBS Newshour is going to be doing a
piece on the Khan Academy this evening
or this afternoon depending on where you
live at least out here in California I
think they show it at 3pm and then at
6pm I think on the East Coast station at
six pm and but you want to check your
local listings and you could also go to
news hour news our dot PBS pbs.org and
one you should be able to find out when
it's showing in your in your local area
and also I made a special video for them
so you can check out to that special
video at Newshour PBS org and and I
think it'll be a favorable take on the
Khan Academy so I hope I don't appoint
yell to a but anyway so watch it
hopefully it'll be good and well we'll
see what what happens see you later